foreign
let's run out to Andrew in Spokane
Washington what's up Andrew
doing pretty good man how about yourself
how's life treating you I I would be uh
lying if I said it was anything other
than pretty awesome but it's pretty good
right now
good that's great to hear what about you
man
uh you know everything's going pretty
good um you know outside of just some
issues going on with Stanley drama
surrounding uh you know getting married
next month yeah family drama that's
weird
so what's up man
um so quick little backstory uh you know
I come from a split home uh parents
split when I was two uh and then got
divorced by the time I was three and as
long as I can remember it's always been
tumultuous you know if one person uh
wasn't gonna is gonna show up to one of
my events growing up
um the other person wouldn't show up
there oh gosh so your parents are
children
I I don't want to word it that way but
yeah I will they're not my mom and dad
okay so they're elementary school kids
fine I'm taking my ball and going home
good job parents way to go essentially
yeah essentially and you know it's gone
through um like probably only a handful
of moments in my life that I can
actually think of that they've been in
person you know like my high school
graduation basic training graduation
those type of things
um well leading to my uh marriage next
month
um you know my dad found out that my mom
was going to be at the rehearsal dinner
and pretty much said outright that he
doesn't want to show up to it and uh bye
Felicia
I mean seriously seriously he is opting
out
gosh that's so heartbreaking man like
I'm making a joke but I'm heartbroken
for you I'm sorry
it's difficult you know because me and
him do have a good relationship overall
and uh but my fiance and I were
discussing like what's gonna happen in
the future when we start having kids and
trying to plan birthdays around them and
those type of things and um and so we
try to discuss it with them you know
we've
um called them and immediately he got
defensive you know saying that we never
stand up for him
um and he has a lot of times in his life
were
doesn't hunt best relationship with
friends or family you know and it's uh
it's been pretty difficult and we didn't
know if it was right for us to confront
him and talk to him about it
um but yeah we just don't really know
how to go forward with it you know it's
been pretty difficult yeah so here's the
language I would use
I would say
um
Dad this is my wedding
and
I'm inviting all of my parents
if you choose to not come
it will break my heart but you're a
grown man and you get to make that
choice I hope to see you there and
that's the end of the conversation
anytime he starts with you nobody ever
sticks up for me you guys have always
said
that Dad I'm not going to continue down
this road
what you're going to start doing is
practicing putting your own two feet
underneath you because you're now
building your own home
and you're building your own legacy in
your own trajectory ideally it would be
part he would be a part of that
and for whatever reason the whole
world's out to get him and he can't see
the forest from the trees and he can't
make hard choices through his own
discomfort for a in service of a larger
picture
and I hate that for you I hate that for
your kids when you have kids it will be
the birthday party will be here
everyone's invited
if you choose to not come because mom
came or if you choose to not come
because Dad came you're a grown-up and I
can't make you be here but it will break
my heart if you don't want to be around
my child
and that's it you you have no other role
to play your job isn't to make him feel
okay about himself
that he's a grown I mean he's your dad
that's his job
tell me why that sounds why that's hard
well you know I try to come from
understand because he did have a lot of
trauma growing up you know there's a lot
of things that he's gone through too but
hold on hold on that was then and this
is now
yeah and if he's going to continue to
let what happened when he was a child
drive the car through adulthood through
grandparenthood
then he is choosing to not be a part of
his son's life in his grandkids life
yeah it's a context not an excuse yes
his childhood was hell I'll give him
that
that doesn't give him license to kick
and scream like a child all through his
50s and 60s and 70s to the point that it
impacts his kids his son's new marriage
his grandkids and on and on into the
future that's how family dysfunction
continues
from generation to generation and you my
friend are being the strong one to say
this stops with me
yeah yeah your childhood was hard too
right
yeah you know I mean I I was blessed
with
um at least having two two parents that
loved me you know so I I try not to
dwell it on too much but you know it's
definitely difficult to balance it and
it was hard yeah I'll dwell on it for
you you don't have to and by the way
when you have a little one it will come
screaming back at you so just be just be
ready but I will uh just you'll remember
this moment you'll be like oh that's
what that idiot on the on the on the
podcast was talking about but I'll I'll
tell you it'll come for you
um and that's all good that's why you're
gonna have a great marriage you're gonna
work hard on having a strong marriage
you're gonna have some men in your life
that you hang out with and do life with
so when this stuff comes
um when those childhood memories come
running back especially when you're
holding your own kids
um you will you'll be absorbed you'll be
able to absorb it right it'll become
part of your life it won't be something
you have to run from and right now your
dad's still running and here's the scary
sucky crappy part you can't fight that
fight for him yeah what you can do is
set boundaries that will help you have a
whole marriage help you be the best dad
you can be to help your kids be whole
um and a lot of that's going to come
with some grief man because you're gonna
have to sit with a broken heart
wondering why your dad's dislike for
your his ex-wife is greater than
his love for his son
and that just hurts man
yeah yeah it's something you know I've
that's exactly how I've worded it you
know and it's something I felt really
long time
um and yeah you know like like you said
I just have to try to continue to do
better and make sure because it stops
here so there's I wouldn't say just just
try to do better I want you to hear me
say you're good enough as you are
you're a good man
I think it's a matter of continuing to
ask yourself what's the best way I can
love my wife what's the best way I can
honor her husband which is Andrew what's
the best way I can love and honor my
kids what's the best way I can serve and
honor love my community my workplace
um my God whatever whatever things you
know are are in the foundation of your
life
um but I think you're doing a pretty
good job the fact you're even asking
these questions and considering drawing
some of these boundaries tells me you're
way down the road man it's impressive
awesome I really appreciate that thank
you so much so here here again just to
reiterate my conversation would be with
my wife
and uh Mark your fiance you're about to
be married in a month and
congratulations
congratulations congratulations by the
way I'm speaking super clearly today I
think I've had 700 milligrams of
caffeine so far today and my tongue is
moving faster than my brain you sounded
like Scooby-Doo I
think I usually do minus the Edibles or
whatever he was always on right I don't
know what Scooby was taking but sorry oh
Shaggy oh Shaggy his owner I think they
were both a little complicit but back to
Andrew back to Andrew I'm a little bit
distracted today
um
yeah I want you to sit down with your
wife and say hey who do we want to
become and what kind of home do we want
to have and that hopefully that home
includes warmth in the home includes
peace
because your home should be a safe place
where you and your spouse and your kids
and your friends and your loved ones
gather
as a shelter for the storm that is The
Madness of the outside world and if
family members bring chaos into that
piece and into that warmth then they are
opting out
and so sit down with your fiance with
your wife and say what do we want what
do we want this to look like what do we
want these boundaries to be and then
begin practicing saying Hey Dad this is
my wedding
so I'm inviting everybody and if you
choose not to come it's gonna break my
heart
but I respect your right to make that
choice if you choose to not be around
our grandkids just because your ex-wife
is there you you choose your hatred or
your anger more than you choose your
grandkid I hate that but you get to do
that and I'll sit in that grief
but I'm not going to budge on my
boundaries
because I'm expanding love here I'm not
trying to constrict
Andrew hang on the line um I'm going to
send you a copy of both own your past
change your future and my brand new book
building a non-anxious life as wedding
gifts
nothing says I love you like a couple of
books about emotional and mental health
right and I'm going to send you both
couples decks
um so that you and your brand new wife
will have something to do for the first
month or two of your marriage or maybe
longer maybe more congratulations my
brother